trois millions de personnes en france
sont touchées par des maladies nos gatti
ou dégénératives et c'est vrai que il
faut des dons pour que la recherche
continue que la recherche avance pour
pouvoir aider toutes ces personnes
malades et donc c'est un élan de
générosité qu'on demande à chaque fois
qu'il ya le téléthon pour que la
solidarité n'est pas un vain mot à la
réunion qui fait partie presque de notre
génétique à nous parce que les gens
aiment partager l données et ben je
crois que même 2 euros ce qu'on peut ce
jour là un peu de son temps parce qu'il
ya plein de bénévoles je voudrais les
remercier aujourd'hui
et bien soyez présents pour ce téléthon
soyez généreux donner un peu de vie même
donné quelques sous c'est la recherche
qui gagnent et en même temps c'est
l'humanité toute entière didac
ensemble et dont les aidants et leurs
familles faites un don de 2 2 le 3
décembre la réunion tel est ton pays
nous défient contre la maladie